استخدام واسع النطاق ومنهجي
للتعذيب، وتأسف اللجنة أيضًا
لحقيقة أن العنف الجنسي المرتبط بالنزاع
لا يزال يحدث في
انتهاك للقانون الإنساني الدولي
وحقوق الإنسان
[موسيقى]
نحن قلقون بشأن مزاعم
الإبادة الجماعية وأننا أه نبحث  تعمقنا
أكثر في هذه القضايا وفيما
يتعلق بذلك ذكرنا أيضاً
أن جانباً من هذا قد يكون مسألة
التحريض أه التي تأتي من بعض
وسائل الإعلام الروسية هناك فرق كبير بين
الانتهاك الروسي بحجم
تلك الانتهاكات والحوادث التي لدينا
اللجنة الموجودة في الجانب الأوكراني تشعر بقلق عميق إزاء
حجم الانتهاكات وخطورتها والأدلة
المستمرة على الجرائم التي ترتكبها
القوات المسلحة الروسية في أوكرانيا،
ونؤكد على ضرورة
المساءلة